nowadays when you think of horror it's
all japanese girls climbing out of
televisions or puppets putting you in
death traps however it seems some of
universals upcoming projects will be
focused on a more classic form of horror
I'm Simon and this is your monster mash
news update universal may not have any
superhero properties but this hasn't
stopped the studio from developing its
own money-spinning blockbuster
franchises the reboot of the mummy which
stars Tom Cruise will kick off a classic
monster universe in 2017 and now a new
film has been added to the release late
as reported by Collider the currently
untitled film is set for a februari 15
20 19 release with the mummy Jew in June
2017 and a second monster movie
scheduled for April 2018 this guarantees
a new film in the ongoing series for at
least the next three years the mummy is
currently in production and last month
images of crews on the London set were
leaked Alex Kurtzman co-writer of the
first two Star Trek movies in the
current reboot series is directing
Kurtzman was hired by Universal in 2014
to develop the new interconnected
franchise in February it was reported
that Johnny Depp will star in the
Invisible Man for the studio it has not
been confirmed whether this movie will
be the second in the series other key
monsters they're expected to be brought
back include the Wolfman van Helsing
Dracula and Frankenstein according to
Variety while cruises and onboard as a
producer of the mummy is expected to
play a major role in the development of
the series do you think anyone could
actually be frightened by Count Dracula
or the Bride of Frankenstein or do you
think these iconic creatures have had
their day let me know in the comments or
come find me on Twitter i'm at the Jagan
all thanks for watching a for your
entertainment news kupic gamespot